okay welcome everybody and welcome to
everyone tuning online
thanks for coming it's our pleasure
today to have no back College visiting
from epfl in Switzerland novaks uh just
about to finish his PhD he's working
with Ian menstrual there and at the
moment he's interning with our friends
from across the lake at Amazon
about to finish the internship there and
then go back and finish up on his PhD
it's great to have another today to talk
about uh to talk about Swag channels
particularly because
Psych is our remaining candidate in the
East standardization process and uh
this is really important work that's
very topical right now to
um
yeah see how to attack and defend the
slice game so pass it over to nodo
thank you Craig for the kind
introduction
so today I'll be presenting psych
channels zero value side Channel attacks
on psych so this is a paper that I
worked on in collaboration with other
people with Luca defeo emerging
and we will present it later this year
at chess in September
um so
I'll be talking about side channels
and I'll be talking about Psych
and how to attack a psych how to attack
psych with the power analysis side
channels so if you know about psych I
guess
most other people on The Talk No it's uh
one of the post Quantum key
encapsulation mechanisms it is uh
currently fighting to be standardized so
a couple of days ago or a couple of
weeks ago nist uh chose uh one uh
algorithm to be standardized which is
kyber but uh Psych is still alive it's
in the fourth round and uh you know now
is the time of analysis of side channels
and uh we have shown some some
weaknesses how to patch them and
hopefully you know it'll go it'll go
further uh through the next round or to
being standardized uh psych means super
singular exogenic encapsulation so
essentially what what it does it
computes isogenes between super singular
elliptic curves
uh if you don't know what exogenes are
that's not too important I'm not going
to discuss exogenous and in the first
part of my talk uh but it is essentially
similar to elliptic curves and similar
to diffie-hellman and uh for the attack
that I'm going to present today it's
essentially same as elliptic curved with
some differences that I'm gonna explain
towards the end so uh elliptic curves
what are elliptic curves these are
geometric objects that are also groups
so a geometric object it means that
elliptic curve is a Formula it is a a
function X and Y which you can write
like this in particular uh we use
elliptic curves which are of the type y
squared equals X cubed plus a squared
plus X
and a is a variable which defines the
curve so for example in psyc when a is
equal to 6 you get one of the curves
which is used in psyc one one of many
um a point on elliptic curve is simply a
pair of coordinates X and Y which lies
on the curve so X and Y which satisfy
the formula in this case the point minus
1 2 if you plug it in it will satisfy
the above formula so -1 2 is the point
on the curve e0 but we will also be
working with General curves with General
A's
um elliptic curves are groups what that
means is that if you have two points you
can add them so there is some operation
like like in the natural numbers if you
have two numbers you can add them well
if you have two points on a curve you
can add them and you can also compute
the negative of a point uh how do you do
that well there's a geometric way to do
that like if you have a point B and a
point Q you draw a line then you draw a
vertical line and the last point of
intersection is point P plus Q
uh there's also an algebraic way to do
it for given a formula and we're gonna
show that formula in the last slide now
if you can add points you can also do
other things with points like you can
compute multiples of a point by adding a
point to itself M times this is how you
get M times p and these are uh the main
objects the main parts uh of site that
that will use today so how do you
compute these elliptic curve group
operations so if you have two points p
and Q represented with their coordinates
X and Y
we want to compute P plus Q Where um
what psyc does is it is smart it doesn't
do it in the standard way but instead it
it tries to save up on Space uh by
representing these points with only
their x coordinates so p
and Q are represented only with their X
and the Y's drop
however if you do that directly then you
lose some information when dropping the
Y so in order to be able to to add these
two points from only their x coordinate
we also need to add a third point which
is Q minus p
and now if we have the x coordinate of P
the x coordinate of Q and the x
coordinate of Q minus B then we can add
B and Q by Simply Computing this value
so we compute one multiplication one
subtraction a square another subtraction
another Square another multiplication
and then we divide these two values
except that we don't actually do that
the reason we don't do that is because
divisions are expensive so if you want
to divide it's going to cost you a lot
and you're going to have an inefficient
algorithm and they're also going to be
other security related problems
um so instead of computing divisions uh
what is done in psyc but also what is
done in general in elliptic curve
cryptography is that points are
represented as in a slightly different
way we use projective coordinates
so
um a number of value X XP is presented
as a pair of values x and z
and what is particular is that this pair
of values they're quotient is equal to
XP so you can think of natural numbers
representing them as rational numbers so
2 is equal to 2 divided by 1 or 4
divided by 2. so you you save the
numerator and the denominator of a
number separately and this is called a
projective coordinates and what's nice
about projective coordinates is that
you can compute things
without dividing you can multiply two
numbers by Computing two multiplications
you can add two numbers by Computing a
couple of multiplications and additions
but you can compute any version
without Computing anything you just swap
the numerator and the denominator and
you have the inverse of a projected
value so
what's good about projective coordinates
is that you don't need to divide and you
can speed up your algorithm
um so what happens in Psych what happens
is that this formula
of adding two elliptic curve points
becomes this formula
so there is an overhead instead of
representing three points with three
coordinates we now represent them with
six coordinates
but uh when you compute the addition you
just compute this value and then the
numerator and the denominator
separately and you save them separately
so
you can speed up the algor
um
now this is uh one property of
projective coordinates but it's not the
main one that I'll be discussing about
today uh what is more important
with respect to projective coordinates
is that they allow some level they give
some level of provide some level of
Defense from side Channel attacks you
can think about the following
so let's say you have some value which
is a a public value a number which is
loaded into a computer which is under
attack so it is being attacked a power
analysis is done on this computer
uh
so this value is going to be loaded
stored it's going to go through the
pipeline it's going to be operated on
and when it is being operated on some
power is being consumed
and uh the power consumption is
proportional to the hemming weight of
the number which is being
operated on to put it in simple terms so
this is a threat model which is valid in
most of the processors today
um and and this creates a problem
this creates a a way to attack protocols
um why well because if we have public
data in the pipeline and this data is
operated on depending on some secret for
example one secret bit and this is what
is done in psyc you have one secret bit
you use it to change some data which is
public then we can simply make a guess
on how that data will update and then we
can do power analysis to see if our
guess was correct like if the the power
consumption was what we would expect it
to be if some gas value would have
passed through the pipeline
um so what we want to do we want to
defend from this and we want that uh
values which are being saved in memory
uh we don't want them to be known we
want to hide them that is we want to
randomize them and this is what
coordinate for uh
for coordinate projective coordinates
allow
so
um one projected coordinate represented
with a numerator and a denominator is
not unique it can be represented in many
different ways in particular so XZ can
be also saved as Lambda X Lambda Z
for any non-zero lamp why well because
the quotient is always the same x
divided by Z is equal to Lambda x
divided by Lambda Z
simple example
um number three you can save it in
memory as a pair three one or you can
save this memory as a pair minus 39 13.
um
and what what's good about this is that
um you can essentially make sure that
the numbers which are stored in your
computer are completely random so uh in
in the beginning what psych did was it
loaded a point represented as X and it
stored it in memory as little X and one
so X was represented as x divided by one
in other words the capital x was Little
X and the capital Z was just one
and this was
or proposed to be patched by randomizing
the coordinates what does that mean that
means you choose a random number and
then you multiply both of the numerator
and the denominator by this random
number
and what happens now is that when this
number is saved in memory it is
completely random
and when this number is saved in memory
it is also completely Rand
so once they enter the pipeline and
start being operated on the the power
consumption done
um when Computing these numbers is is
random like you cannot you lose this
correlation between the power
consumption and the values themselves
and this is true so this number is
completely random in all cases except
for one
and
that case
is the case when a coordinate is equal
to zero and this is where the zero
values comes from in the title of our
presentation and so if a number is zero
you multiply by random value you're
gonna get zero again
and this was uh what we try to exploit
and we formalized our attack in the
following manner so we want to force a
Target party which is Computing side we
wanted to we want to force it to compute
some point which has one of the
coordinates equal to zero because then
we know how that will reflect to power
consumption and if we have access to
power measurement we can we can gather
that information
um there are two points two such points
in in Psych there is the point one zero
and the point zero one so the first
point is known as the appointed Infinity
on elliptic curves and the second point
is particular to psych it's a it's a
special point
um okay so let me
explain psych finally what psych does a
typical execution of Psych
takes his input
a triple of x coordinates of points p q
and P minus Q
uh as explained previously and then a
secret which is a secret number which is
a random natural number
the party which computes psych does that
in the three following step first there
is the initialization step where these
three are fine coordinates are turned
into three elliptic coins uh in in
projected form and they are we can
assume that they are randomized
then these three projective points are
funneled to a three-point ladder which
is uh something similar to scalar
multiplication on regular elliptic
curves and we use them to compute a new
elliptic curve point at the point P plus
s k times Q
this new point is called R and then in
the third step of psyc the point R is
used to compute a secret exogeny so
starting from the starting curve the
target computes an exogeny to another
curve and this final curve is a secret a
common Secret so today I will only cover
the attack on the three-point ladder
however in our work we also did an
attack on the Exogen computation and I
have some extra slides for that so maybe
after we talk I can I can get it from a
little more details on these argument
computation
um so the three-point ladder
is
um as I said it is essentially scalar
multiplication on elliptic curves it
works in the following way so you take
three points you're saying you assign
them to new three variables r0 is Q R1
is PR2 is Q minus p and then you go
through all the bits of the secret key
and you do the following so if the
secret bit is zero if the secret bit is
one you will add r0 to R1 if the secret
bit is zero you will throw it away
and by throw it away I mean you will add
it to the second variable which is kind
of a dummy variable
um and then at every step you double r0
and if you think about it what happens
is you take Q you double it at every
step and then whenever secret bit is one
you add it to p and it's not so
difficult to see that the final outcome
uh this point P will be updated to the
point P plus skq which is exactly the
secret point which we're looking for
so the question which we posed ourselves
was okay
um what happens during this Loop and how
can we
make sure that
one of these three points for example
the point R2
is he has one of the coordinates equal
to zero
um during the execution
so
what happens at step k
would be the the main question if we
posed also
um so our attack works in the following
way so we extract secret bits from the
target party one by one so first we
attack the bottom most bit then the
first bit then the second bit and so on
and uh what we always do is that we
assume that we have all K minus one bits
in order to be able to attack bit K and
to extract
so we let's start by assuming that we
have like the first K minus one bits of
the secret key which are represented
like this
if we know this value then there are
only two options
um in the three-point letter at step K
and these two options depend only on the
Kate bit
and if you develop the formula from
previous slide you will see that the
third bit is either going to be equal
the third point is zero going to be
equal to this value
which depends only on some known
information or it is going to be equal
to this value if the secret key bit is
one
which also can be pre-computed right if
we have PQ and we have the secret key
the known part of the sequence
um and this later leads us to the attack
so the attack works as follows
I want to extract sacred bit K I assume
that I know all the previous secret bits
when we compute the public key a
maliciously generated public key
it's made out of three points QP and Q
minus B so I select Q to be a random
point on a random curve I select B to be
equal to this value over here
and Q minus p is the difference of those
two points
Compares them compress them into a
public key and send them to the Target
now the target starts Computing the
three-point letter and at step K the
following thing happens so the third
variable R2
is going to be equal to the point T
which was the point zero one or zero
something random if there was an
organization
if
the secret key bit as step K is 0 or it
is going to be equal to something
completely random and non-zero I can
assure you of that if the secret key bit
is one
so in other words we get a zero
coordinate or a zero point if and only
if
a bit of the secret key is equal to zero
so what do we do then will we do
parallels
we measure the power consumption of the
computer we zoom in at the Kate step of
the loop and then we see what happens
and then we make a guess was this zero
or was this not a zero and if we make a
correct guess we repeat we go to the
next bit
how does this look in practice
it looks like this so it's actually not
power analysis this is electromagnetic
signal analysis so it's it's done even
without touching the the wires or the
the processor
um so it is a bit weaker but it is
strong enough so this is how the
computation of the three-point letter
looks these are the first 20-ish
steps of the loop
and this is the case where uh the value
is not zero this on the other hand is
the case where you get the value 0 at
step 12 if I remember correct so if you
count these spikes somewhere around here
is 12 step 12 of The Loop and you can
see that the power consumption suddenly
becomes kind of atypical because you
have all zeros
um
now maybe somebody's watching this
presentation from their phone and they
say oh but I I don't really see the
difference looks pretty pretty equal to
me so I'm gonna say okay don't worry
that's not all there's actually more to
it there is another point with zeros
uh and this is the point zero zero
and uh let me show you how to compute
this point
so
if you remember the formula for Point
Edition it looks a bit something like
this
and adding two points it depends on
three
it has three inputs b q and P minus Q or
Q minus p
well
when the point Q minus p
is equal to the point T which is the
point zero one or zero something
then if you Analyze This formula
correctly you will see that the point P
plus Q will always be equal to zero zero
right
so and how does this relate to the
previous attack well in the previous
attack we showed that if the secret key
bit is zero then the third Point R2
is equal to the point t to the point
zero something and the point R2 it it's
kind of it's a q minus P it is r0 minus
R1
so
what happens is that the point r0 plus
R1 which is uh uh being updated in the
loop
becomes 0 0.
and uh one might think okay this is nice
so instead of one zeros I'm gonna get
three zeros so
this uh that that graph that I showed
before it's it's gonna have like
spikes three times as large not really
actually there's there's much more than
that so the point zero zero is it's kind
of special it's not a projective point
if you did projective geometry you will
say oh but there's not even a point this
is zero divided by zero it doesn't mean
anything
well not only that it does mean anything
but it has a very nice property uh if
you have this point as an input it's
always going to be an output so whenever
you compute something if 0 0 is one of
the inputs you can have multiple inputs
it's the output is going to be zero zero
and this is nice because it leads to an
avalanche effect if you compute zero
zero one time then every other variable
from that point on
written in your memory saved in your
computer going through the pipeline is
going to be zero
so until the end of the computation of
Psych you're only going to have zeros
and this is pretty easy to exploit using
side channel so if you think about it
you have to distinguish two cases run an
algorithm everything in memory is zero
or run the same algorithm but the values
in memory are random
and if you have access to power
consumption
this becomes pretty easy to distinguish
so somebody might have noticed that on
the previous slide I have cropped this
picture because we never did an attack
by only looking for one zero we were
looking for this Avalanche of zeros and
over here we had the first zero
happening so that point T the point zero
something was computed here and it led
to an avalanche and then from this point
onwards
you can clearly distinguish the power
consumption uh between
uh having all zeros in memory which is
shown on the bottom slide or having
random values in memory which is shown
in the top it's just a single tricks
this is just a single trace yeah this is
a single Trade Center and this is only
20 steps of the Dublin ad of the
three-point ladder Loop this Loop goes
on for about 250 steps so you can think
that this continues for a long time and
it doesn't finish there because the
three-point letter is the first part of
Psych this is about 20 of the runtime
later you have another eighty percent of
the run time when a similar uh thing
continues so it becomes awfully easy to
notice with side channels
um and um of course a natural question
to ask is okay how do we how do we
defend from that uh well the the
one way to defend which is pretty easy
uh if if you look at it closely you'll
see that the problem or one of the
problem is that the points that are
generated are generated maliciously they
don't satisfy among the other things
they don't satisfy an order formula or
Independence I didn't explain what
Independence was but you can think like
they're a thing corrector so if you
check that their of correct order and
that the input the three input points
are independent and this is not
difficult to check
then we have shown in our paper that you
will never get a single zero throughout
the whole computational cycle
so it's a good way to defend from the
whole attack however there is a problem
with this counter measurement I mean
the problem is the cost it's around 10
percent and psych well I didn't mention
this in the beginning but psych has a
some drawbacks is that it is the slowest
of of all post Quantum algorithms but it
also has the smallest keys but it is
slow so this additional overhead uh is
is just you know it's a bigger problem
than than it would be for some other
algorithms
uh now before I finish I wanted to
mention three uh more things the first
thing is uh how does say compare to ecdh
this is my point of view like why why
this attack happens
um
well easy the age first of all
elliptic curve difficult man it has only
one curve
so an elliptic curve difficult you don't
get to choose a curve you get one curve
this curve is hard coded into the
algorithm it's not that somebody gives
you the coordinates of the curve no it's
saved in memory already and you cannot
mess with it in Psych there are many
Curves in in a in an honest execution of
Psych you expect to get some random
curve right and that just means there's
a bigger surface of attack
another problem is that the Curves in
elliptic curved if you heldman they're
fixed but they have an order which is
let me call it nice so the order is a
large prime number or at most a small
multiple of a large prime number I don't
know a single curve
which doesn't which is used in crypto
and does not have one of these three
orders so Q4 Q or 8 Q
on the other hand it's Psych
the order is highly factorizable
so it's a it's a multiple of a large
part of two and a large power of three
and uh
this is if you're being honest
however psych doesn't check the order of
the curve when you receive it as an
input so if you're malicious you could
take a curve of a different order
and there are many curves so who knows
what other malicious things you could do
third thing let the curved
diffie-hellman uses only 1.4 input so if
you remember diffie-hellman
I send you
G you compute G to DX or I send you an
elliptic curve point you compute x times
that lift the curve Point well for psych
it's not the same for site you get three
points
and you need to set at least two
so this
also becomes a problem this is actually
the reason why we cannot like we
couldn't do this attack that I just
presented in ecdh uh among other reasons
because there's only one input point
um
and this input Point not only there's
only one of it it has a a small number
of orders that you can choose from like
if it's on the curve then it has one of
these four orders because Q is a large
Prime so you don't really divide Q by
much by something other than Q itself
and what
in psyc uh we we get the the previous
problem again since the order is so
highly factorizable you can get points
uh of many different orders so this
would be something like 250 times 150
different possibilities for orders four
points on psych and again if you're
being honest with the Curve
um and finally in ecdh if you want to
check that the point is a correct order
that's easy
you can do it in a negligible time
but in Psych
this this cause uh well actually I I
just noticed that this this was wrong
what I've written in this slide I wrote
that uh the check that the points are
honestly generated is costly no the the
check that the points are of correct
order is costly and it is around 10
percent of runtime but you don't get
honesty you you don't get the proof that
they're honestly generated they could be
of the correct order but there could be
something else malicious done on them
and as far as I know and I believe that
it's probably
very it's very hard to prove that points
are honestly generated probably as hard
as breaking Psych
um
okay
um so second thing
before I wrap up I mentioned that we did
two attacks one attacks on the
three-point ladder and another attack on
the exogeny and both attacks are similar
in that we force this Avalanche of the
uh effect so we we for the computation
of a point zero zero and then there's
effect however I believe that there are
some deep differences in how these two
things happen in the two cases in the
three-point letter the problem is that
the formula is not complete and
I guess some people know what that means
I'm not going to get into explaining
that this is on one side it's
unavoidable on elliptic curves on the
other side it can be avoided and
and again I and and this makes sense
what I just said
um
and and so if you think about it we
complete we computed something which
makes sense we added two elliptic curve
points it was the formula that was the
problem the formula at these two points
it gives you zero zero and actually if
you go deeper into it those two zeros
they cancel out in a smart way and you
can get something which is Meaningful
in the second attack the exogeny attack
uh the problem is deeper we we force the
target to compute something completely
nonsensical
and and it computes things which don't
make sense like points which are not on
the elliptic curve isogenes which have
bad kernel things which are not
algebraic and then it just messes up so
much that you get a zero zero in the end
so I think you know if you think about
this that there is uh more to be
analyzed in the exogeny and there are
some additional threats coming from
there
um and now to end I I just wanted to
explain
how the hertzbleed attack works so
a couple of weeks ago this new attack on
info processor was published this this
was not done by me so this was done by a
different team but they used the same
exact attack that I just showed you as a
proof of concept for an attack for a
timing attack on x86 processors so I
presented a power analysis stack
and they showed they exploited the
weakness of a x86 to translate this
attack to timing attack
uh so how is this done well
essentially
um they target
um
processors x86 processors with turbo
boost
and turbo boost is important here turbo
boost and dynamic voltage and frequency
scaling so what is dvfs essentially you
can think about it this way you have a
processor at clocks at four gigahertz
and then you turn on dvfs and dvfs says
okay I'm going to allow you to work
between three gigahertz and five
gigahertz
because I'm good
and of course you say well I mean that's
great I'm just gonna start bumping at
five gigahertz because I I want to be
faster you know I want to do more and it
starts Computing a lot faster but there
can be problems with that for example
you can start running out of battery
because if you compute faster you use
more energy
or you could start overheating
and so if you start overheating the
controller steps in and says oh wait the
CPU temperature is too high you cannot
continue Computing at five gigahertz
because you're gonna you're gonna burn
so let me lower the frequency to three
gigahertz so that it cools down and then
I can let you compute fast later again
and this I think in essence can be
captured in two formulas
first one is that the power is
proportional to the voltage squared
times frequency
and the second formula is that the
voltage is proportional
to the Hemingway are of the machine
words in memory or to the this hemming
distance between consecutive machine
words or you can think about it to the
number of bits that are flipped
when you come when you flip bits you
need to use an energy to flip a bit or
write a zero so it's proportional to be
and so uh essentially works in the
following way suppose you have a lot of
bits to flip right well you flip more
bits you need more current
well if you need more current
you increase the power
and if you increase the power the
temperature of the CPU increases
but if the temperature increases then
the controller steps in and says okay
you're overheating I need to lower the
frequency
but if you lower the frequency you
increase the run time because that is
what frequency means
and therefore you can uh extend this
attack
really easily so if you remember the the
attack from a couple of sides before if
your secret key bit is zero
then you compute the projected point
zero zero but if you compute the
projected point zero zero you get the
Avalanche effect what does that mean all
the variables are zero all the variables
are zero you never flip a single bit so
you use less current and you can obtain
a faster runtime
the other hand if a secret key bit is
one then all the variables are you you
don't get a zero zero you get random and
all the valuables are random and all the
Heming weights are random and you flip
bits and you use more current and you
get a slower runtime
and this difference in runtimes it's
it's not Stark it's not like you get a
second more but you can definitely
notice it uh if you run the attack
enough time so this is from the
hertzblade paper and this is a histogram
of the runtimes for the two cases
uh when a secret key bit is equal to one
another secret to get bit secret key bit
is equal to zero so yeah sometimes one
can be faster than the other but on
average if you have zero more zeros
you're gonna be faster
and this simply shows how to extend a
par analysis deck to timing attack
and therefore to a long distance attack
and so on but also as I said before
you do the point order check and you fix
it
and uh and this covers my talk thank you
for your attention
we see some things clapping up on the
thing just
thank you thanks thanks very much
um
we might have time for the isogeny party
if you if you're happy to do that but
I'll ask if anyone wants to ask
questions at this point if that's all
right yes so yeah any any questions from
well from the audience here or from the
audience online you can either you can
either type them into the chat and I'll
relay them or I can uh or you can unmute
and ask your question directly if you
like
any any questions out there check the
picture
touch bathroom floors
great okay so I've only got one question
at this point
um
the
performance of
using Montgomery is basically identical
to using Edwards roughly speaking okay
just do it
so I think that
the points of small order on Edwards on
the Edwards curve if it's defining the
right way don't have any zero values
yeah I mean that's what Edwards Edwards
Corners do you kind of make the the the
formula complete by moving them in an
extension yeah that wasn't even buried
off in the extension field so it would
not be was
just
reach the whole Library Avenue Edwards
uh well I guess you could offend defend
from the three-point ladder but I don't
think you could defend from the exogeny
attack
and also I don't know how these formulas
look on these objects yeah
because right because you fixed the the
um the problem of formulas being
complete
that's not the only problem so this is
just like you this only fixes the
addition formula which is complete right
the isogeny can also output a zero zero
and I don't know
yeah exactly
so
I'm not sure
uh
I don't even know how exogenic formulas
look on Android skirt would there be as
additions
and I'm also not sure that when it when
a curve has such a smooth order like
that if if you still get to vary the
points yeah that's kind of odd because
this is like
kind of important at that point I I
you know you use these
um
yeah I don't know if you could throw it
out at an extension field because
um
because you use points that are about it
so so it definitely cannot be in an
extension field but maybe you know maybe
it's something
cool
um
usually I'd say thanks again and wrap up
but I'm I'm trying to hear the the other
slides if you're happy yeah I will I
will if I was online we might we're
going to continue with the
um the auxiliary part of the talk which
is to hear more about the isogony
attacks right
yeah people carry on since we've got
time that would be great if you don't
mind okay
uh oh yeah so these are the people from
the cards newspaper just want to give
them credit support their work
um
so let me jump over this uh outliner the
isogeny attack so the idea is that
I want to force
the kernel generating point of the
exogeny to have order a power of two
when you compare the three eyes actually
so you can also attack the two eyesogeny
with a power of three point or any L
isogeny with an L Prime order point
um and and we showed that there is a a
special number called the breaking point
such that if
the order of this point is 2 to the r
well when R is smaller than the breaking
point then you always get zero value
and Avalanche
if the order of the point is to the to
the r with r greater than the breaking
point then you get no zero values and
everything is right
and this
you can do in two steps
so
I'll show first how to
how to force the order
to be the way we want it so we can we
can force the order of uh the
chronological point to be 2 to the r
plus minus one
plus one or plus zero essentially
depending on the secret key bit so
either 2 to the r or two to the r minus
1 for any R and and in particular we're
going to use 2 to the o or two to the O
minus one to always fall into one of
these two cases depending on the secret
and once you have that
will show what what happens if R is of
this bad order how and why do you get
all those zeros
order forcing is a
it's very simple but the formulas look
large essentially
you you take a point of order 2 to the r
minus 1.
and uh
and
then
you kind of want that to be p
and then you take Q to be an independent
point
of order 2 to the r
plus K where K is the bit that you want
to expect a compute
and then you update B by subtracting the
known secret key part of Q because you
you want to get rid of this you go one
to start from Bitcoin right
and so when you compute P plus skq now
well p is the point of order 2 to the r
minus one line is this the Q and Q you
just develop uh SK
um
the whole SK so this is the known part
and this is starting from the K bits
upwards and of course these two cancel
out so the minus known part in the known
part
and you're left with the S point of
order 2 to the r minus 1.
2 to the K times Q which
this kind of K cancels out so you get a
point of order 2 to the r
and then another like the remainder
which is a point of order 2 to the r
minus 1 or smaller
because this would be like 2 to the K
plus 1 times Q so you lose K plus 1 in
the exponent
of the order
right so this you can kind of ignore
and you get either
s which is a point of two to the r minus
1.
plus a point of order 2 to the r if the
secret key bit is one so you get a point
four or two to the r right
or if this is zero you get a point of
order 2 to the r minus one and then
another point that which is independent
from it too so they really can't cancel
out you know you don't care
and and therefore we you can control you
can do the trick you know if you know
the previous bits based on this next bit
you can control the order of the kernel
point it's either 2 to the r minus one
or two TR and this is for every R almost
every r i mean maybe not when R is
higher than what is the size of the
curve something like that but
almost all ours
okay and um
and that was simple but what happens
during Exogen computation so isogeny it
would uh
works as follows so let's say Bob who's
the target computer three to the i3a
zodge and an exogeny is I mean you know
this but I didn't remove it from the
slides
it is a hard-coded sequence of the
following operations you do trip links
on an elliptic curve
you take a kernel point of order three
you compute the image curve through a
three eyesogeny
and then
with the same Exogen you can push some
point onto the next curve
and another thing is you can save and
load a point
these are the four operations which is
which are used in a subject computation
and the order in which you do them is
saved in what is called a strategy
so for example how does it look to
compute an exogeny of degree 3 to the
power 7 let's say you started some curve
e0 and you have a some point R on this
curve
uh well you take this point and you
start multiplying it with three so you
compute 3r 9R 27r so on and so on and so
on until you get
to obtain a point of order three which
is three to the 6 times R you use this
point as kernel to compute the next
curve and then you start Computing
isogenes to push some saved points to
the next curve then you do the same with
the next Point next curve push points
then you do the save and sometimes you
might have to triple it
and so on and so on until you get to the
final curve and you finish your exogenic
computation so this thing can be very
nicely represented in a tree
um so what happens if a if a kernel has
a bad order like if this point R is not
of the order three to the seven or three
to whatever it needs to be
well
you're on the starting curve you Triple
R so even if it's of the band order
you're still gonna triple it and it's
gonna work right and some of these
points which are triple they're going to
be saved
and this is still okay
but then
you start Computing a 3i Dodge
and this is the first problem so your
computer three isogeny but your point is
of the bed order what happens well what
happens is that you get something
nonsensical
right you're going to get a random curve
and you're going to get random image
points the image points don't have to be
on the curve the curve doesn't have to
be exogenous it doesn't have to be super
singular it it you know it doesn't have
to be occur I mean it's going to be a
curve because you get a coefficient but
you know it doesn't make sense
um well they'll and they're going to
stay random until the end of the
protocol because like you then you're
not even on elliptic curves you just
compute random stuff with random things
right so you kind of expect to get all
random things until the end uh until the
end of Psych
you do
except in some cases so
there are some things which are not
random and this is kind of expected it
it makes sense like even if an exogeny
is a nonsensical isogeny with a nonsense
called kernel it's going to send the
point of infinity to point Infinity
because of the way they are constructed
even if the exogeny is a nonsensical
exogeny
uh if the kernel point of the isogeny is
equal to the input point of the exogeny
the output point is going to be the
point of infinity
which yeah it kind of makes sense you
you want
like exogenes need to have that property
for for good kernel points so uh it
happens also if the program points are
bad
um and then there's one property which
is Formula related is that if your
kernel is the point in affinity
then you get a degenerate curve
the generate curve it means the curve of
coefficients equal 1 divided by zero and
then however you represent that in
projective coordinates they're different
representations
um and the final property
is that if you happen to compute a zero
and if you happen to be under the
generate curve and if you just so happen
to Triple that point zero on the
generate curve well you're gonna get
zero zero
and this is what we can get
so how does that work well
there is a nice if and only if
for getting the zero zero zero zero
happens if and only if one of the two
following properties
either two of the points which are saved
on The Starting curve are equal
or if two of the points
are different by T
probably remember what T was if they
have flipped coordinates but this has
also a deeper algebraic meaning is that
one is equal to the other one plus that
point t 0 1 over 2.
so let me just explain the first case
but the other case is essentially
identical
what happens if you have two equal
points
on the starting curve which are saved
well they're going to be sent to the
same points with the Exogen even though
the Exogen is nonsensical it is a it's a
function and a function sends the same
thing to the same thing it's that's what
it what the definition of a function is
and since they're going to preserve this
equality eventually one of them is going
to be used to compute an exogeny as a
kernel point the image of one
of it well when you confuse it as a
kernel point then you're going to send
the other point to the pointed Infinity
because of the property mentioned on a
previous slide
and that point of infinity is going to
be preserved because you're going to
push it with exogenes to the point
Infinity you're going to triple it to
the point of infinity so it's just going
to stay there until eventually you use
it to compute uh an exogeny use it as a
kernel so you compute the exogeny and
the image curve is going to be
degenerate but then you're going to also
push that zero to the image curve and
eventually you're going to triple it and
eventually you're going to get that zero
zero
and I have a very nice explanation of
how that actually looks so let's start
off a point with a point of a bed order
on the curve where we want to compute an
exogeny of the power of three to the
power 10. oh so we triple triple triple
triple triple
until we get to what we expect to be a
point of order three but is essentially
a point of order 2 to the something
and let's suppose that these two large
points that the fat ones this one this
one
are equal
well we use this point to compute an
exogeny and what happens well the next
curve is random not a curve blue means
nonsensical
so we push the first point to something
Rand we pushed the large point to
something random but the other large
Point goes to the same thing so fat
means equal
we push this point to something random
and we continue now again Computing
exogeny random Point random misogyny
nonsensical everything stays Blue but
the fat Point stays fat
now compute an exogeny with one of the
two equal points
the curve is again something random
because the point is the random itself
but the image of the other point becomes
a point at Infinity represented in light
blue
and now we continue take this point
Infinity triple it we're on a random
curve so tripling is good I mean you're
gonna get still the point of infinity
triple triple triple oh it's the kernel
of exogeny computing exogeny bam you get
a degenerate curve represented as blue
so we continue you approach the random
Point happens to be a random Point
um
you push the point in Infinity into the
point of Infinity but now oh excuse me
and then you draw another exogeny and it
stays the same because the exogeny again
has zero for a kernel so the next curve
is the generate you push the two things
and finally you need to Triple the point
of infinity at the generate curve
what do you get you get the point zero
zero what happens when you get the point
zero zero everything becomes zero all
isogenes all points all curves
are zero zero
and this will happen until the end of
year
usually this happens like in the first
20 to 30 percent of this graph
but uh
I can might even show you later one of
the pictures of that
um and and finally how do we get
uh two equal points on the starting
curve
um well that's that's pretty simple
because if you think about it what are
the Saved points like they're saved in
the Exogen it's simply some indices I
such that 3 to the I are is saved so
like it's 10 points usually
or log of e three points
and when are two points equal
they're equally if and only if
3 to the alpha R equals 30 beta r
for some uh Alpha Beta in the index set
and somebody will say yeah plus minus
yeah plus minus
let's not be too detailed here
um and what what is this well this is
just a a modular equation because the
point R is of some order 2 to the r then
this is just a modular equation modulo
to TBR
and uh
what happens is that not only is just
the model equations but if you have a
solution modulo 2 to the r you will have
a solution module 2 to the r minus 1.
because it projects
and therefore if you have the strategy
and the strategy is public you can show
that there is this breaking point you
can always find some R which is so large
that for any pair of indices this
formula here becomes non-zero
and therefore if it's true for R it's
true for all the exponents larger than r
and you will be able to find some R
whether where this equation is equal to
zero so it will be equal to zero from
our onwards down up to R is equal to
zero if you think about it let's say R
is equal to zero what does that mean
that means the point is the point is
infinity well of course it's going to
repeat right because it you triple it
into itself so there's always some
solution but the more you go up
eventually you're going to run out of
solutions they're like you can even get
a heuristic argument why that is always
going to be the same because you have a
small number of indices but the exponent
is so large so you can you don't expect
to get an equate equality here and also
you can like Factor this out so
I don't think
maybe you could do like a very
inefficient strategy to to try to fix
this but you can't run away from it
um
and this doesn't actually only work as I
said before in the three eyesogen it
works uh on the two Exogen and the three
isogeny on any L isogeny on any curve
which has an l and l Prime is arginine
you can do this attack and in particular
these are the exponents
for these uh parameters of Psych
and here the exponent is very low
because in this curve you'll remember
like the two isogenes are actually
computed with four eyesogenes but but on
this curve you do
Toys R Us in the first step and later
you do the four isogenes and that we
thought it was going to be problematic
but actually it's even easier to attack
that
um and and for the end this this is how
it looks
uh it's it's not so clear the picture
but
um this is uh uh how it looks in
practice so this is a three to the 137
so this is the smallest parameter set of
site we send the point of order two to
the eighth and the point of order two to
the nine would have everything dark blue
until the end so everything would be
completely random a point of order 228
it this point here denoted with a star
you can zoom in enough and this same
point here denoted with a star they
happen to be equal
so when this isogen is computed pushes
it to the point of infinity propagates
blah blah and eventually over here
if you zoom in enough you get a small
first red exogeny and 0.00 and then it's
going to propagate until the end
and uh and that's it and well since I
just have a couple more slides I can
just add it how we attack this with side
channel is that we just computed two
baselines essentially we gave you
something which is always going to be
zero independent of your secret key and
then we give you something which is
never zero independent of your secrets
and then we just correlate this Power
Trace with the power press extracted for
each bits and and what we get when we
compute this correlation is the
following so either you get the
correlation of 0.99 were you correct or
0.3 when you're incorrect so
it's pretty it's pretty easy
and uh and that covers the Exogen attack
and my presentation thank you
thanks
again
quickly to the audience once again in
case any new questions have popped up
the chat
you can also unmute again if you weren't
trying to make a question anyone
yeah absolutely thank you okay
if not let's
thing go back again